with images like photos the total file
size depends on the number of pixels
multiplied by the number of bits it
takes to storage pixel so to improve
performance you need to keep images as
small as possible and compression as
high as possible it's a common mistake
to save images with dimensions too large
and quality too high it might sound
counterintuitive but the first rule for
serving images to a range of devices is
to save images with the lowest possible
quality and the smallest size as
possible but how do you reduce file size
while maintaining quality throughout
this course you'll learn how to use
responsive techniques to do just that